what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we got ourselves a trailer
for The Beetle that is blue John how are you I am
unbelievably excited oh you're making me feel a
boost of golden Smiles ladies and gentlemen
leave a like are you gonna watch this DC
movie in the theaters I hope you do Jaime Reyes
coming in at ya Let's see what's going on today
[Music] excuse me Mr Reyes you finished scraping
the gum off that lounger or what all right
I think right now you always land
on your feet bro you're hymen Corgi
this record I think so they
don't get out much where's Ted
I like the colors games but do not open it you
went in to get a shot Big Valley Burger okay I
don't think it's a burger you haven't looked
what the hell is this speed up Works how did
you get it to do that I think he likes
me whoa freaking George Lucas whoa oh wow
yes Megan horrific
that looks painful [Music] painful
scare of sight guys
oh
it looks great re-entry systems ready that
sounds like Karen is saying what you want
to touch with the hand of the water it's called
this character it's some kind of world destroying
weapons it's designed to protect its host do
you see in the buses sometimes it does what
you want and sometimes it does it I like
the Scarab side yeah it's like I I think I
cut a bus in half whoa Matrix it belongs to me
hello you feel for your family makes you weak
awesome awesome cheats to actions the
universe is a sensual gift family is
involved that's what you're going to do with it
whatever you can imagine
let's do this all right oh I love the Weaponry
giant anime Sword I love the Weaponry yes
sweets
whoa It's like Batman stuff Batman's a fascist
oh damn excited to talk about it let's talk about
it I mean yeah look like full disclosure I'm
not exactly like a Blue Beetle expert by any
stretch and if you're one of McCoy genre is he's
hosting some big panels at Megacon right now the
weekend of a bunch of trailers that are coming
out I'm familiar with bloop I've played the
Injustice games I've seen another animated medium
crossovers I've read some comics where Blue Beetle
does appear and I think you just watched the
DC animated movie versus Teen Titans he squares
off with Damien Wayne so I loved seeing all the
powers fully realized here from uh I think the
terminology is like technomorphy when it comes
to the Weaponry the manipulation abilities the
Scarab sighting the flight obviously a lot of
this movie has this family Vibe I have three
movies that came to mind when watching let's
see if they're the same spot of Iron Man Shazam
the first one and Venom oh exactly three of those
movies feel like they're they're at play here sure
and it's cool that Blue Beetle is getting this
opportunity to shine because I believe that Jaime
Reyes he came into the fold around the new 52 era
because he's like the third Blue Beetle like the
mainly popular one but prior to Jaime Reyes was
Ted cord and I I need to rewind this did that say
chord on the building because I heard the rumor
being that Susan Sarandon's character is kod yeah
is the sister of Ted cord perhaps we'll get a tet
Court cameo in here because Ted cord was the Blue
Beetle then eventually it was Jaime Reyes so
yeah I imagine that it'll somehow link to Ted
Court ultimately we got Booster Gold who's gonna
be having his own DC animated property in the DCU
so I feel like Blue Beetle is here to stay around
because Blue Beetle and Booster Gold a big part
of what boosted the popularity of Blue Beetle was
the combination of the two of them but how do you
pronounce his name my God I feel so bad for never
getting it they're all good I can't just always
call him Miguel from Cobra the casting director
was like get me Miguel he's the perfect character
he is the perfect guy to be playing this because
yeah it has like the family Dynamics a Scarab I
don't know if they're gonna go full out here with
how much communication abilities the Scarab does
have you know being able to have like full-on
conversations with him but I think there's
like some humor to generate from there I think it
might be more along the lines of like Spider-Man
homecoming yeah yeah totally I'm curious to see
how they play that because it didn't feel quite as
much like a living alien entity in this portrayal
as it does like an advanced AI that powers the
suit so I'm curious to see how the lore kind of
accounts for that but yeah I mean how much uh
intelligence does the suit actually have what what
availability it seems like they can communicate
pretty well she's like upset assessing his weapon
choices and all that stuff doesn't seem like
there'll be too much of a barrier there necessary
necessarily but even so I mean I think it would
be fun to watch him have to learn the suit but
especially for just like Charming the world and
giving everybody their a lot of people is going
to be the first they've heard of Blue Beetle as
a character at all simplifying that a little
bit is probably a good thing for the general
audience and it's not like the main point but
yeah like this just looks so much fun and those
are the exact kind of movies that came to mind
a little bit of upgrade too when he's actually
going through like the first suit transformation
which was compared to Venom definitely exactly
he's pretty much yeah so you got better this
looks really fun and colorful and bouncy and
and something that I could see on a streaming
scenario but I'm glad that they boosted this
to the theatrical because this again looks like
something that can have that level of fun that
they were looking for in something like a Shazam
but that also seems like it's got some potential
to be like a semi at least not like gritty-gritty
but like a bit of an effect in Coming of Age story
too because oh a thousand percent yeah and like
the transformation as I understand it is supposed
to be a bit painful and it certainly looks like
it is here and so just like that relationship I
think will be really fascinating to see and two
with this being placed after flash like doing
a little bit of reading on like the history
of the character in general like this wasn't
even always a DC character and Blue Beetle was
co-opted into DC I think after like Crisis it
was around the time of I think Peacemaker was
part of the same company prior I think this
coming right after the flash will actually kind
of probably bode well for his inclusion uh in the
future and then having Damien Wayne in the mix
as well I think I'll just make for some really
fun potential Teen Titans stuff I love the way
the weapons are realized that you said anime
during the reaction and it does have that anime
Flair too sure yeah like it looks breathtaking
yeah it's beautiful to look at it's beautiful
to behold yeah and that's the thing is like
this could easily look like big bad Beetleborgs
and it doesn't it looks like it has that fun and
I like that they kept the heads up display as
something that looks a little more cartoon and
a little more of the natural world I guess it's
a little more organic feeling and I think that's
cool but like his just the suit and the look of
the effects and everything is like Top Notch so
I'm I don't know what kind of influx of money they
got for this but it seems to certainly be paying
off well I love the choice of the cinematography
here because I'm a filmmaking level you do get
this great color palette of a lot of purple and
blue Shades throughout this entire aesthetic yeah
and you got George Lopez you got George Lopez and
you got the girl from Hocus Pocus who oh and big
belly burger that is a a reoccurring restaurant
within I don't know if it's been in the I think
it was in the arrowverse at one point it's like a
reoccurring fast food restaurant in the in the DC
world I feel like it's been some of the animated
stuff ever yeah it must have been uh but yeah to
see it in live action I think is really fun oh
sure uh but yeah no I I thought this trailer was
a lot of fun really exciting I hope this movie
is a hit because I like Blue Beetle to carry on
into the DC Universe especially to interact with
the members in the play the new Booster Gold but
yeah guys thank you so much for being here leave
a like what did you think about this trailer leave
your thoughts down below uh be sure to subscribe
click that Bell hey let's send this with a pink
Ricardo Martinez we've got ourselves a Latin
superhero and we got ourselves a Latino to
shout out Ricardo you sexy sexy beast you I
would love for the Scarab to attach itself
to your body so that way you can come fly over
here and pay us a visit that would be the main
thing we would just want to take advantage of
your powers and we can go traveling and stuff
and I'd have you beat up my arch nemesis for
me blind wave they're in Ohio fly us over to
Ohio get Eric yeah yeah it's great no man
it's great to be having you at our patreon
page and I'm curious to know how you feel man
we don't do we is there is this the first like
Latin superhero Latino I keep saying Latin Latino
front and center I I believe it is or at least in
a way where it's like you know overtly part of
the character's personality I mean we've had you
know the The Ghost Writer uh uh Robbie Reyes but
uh yeah you know not in a full you know Fleet of
a cinematic Motion Picture well it's time to take
that pride in my friend because you've earned it
for being a super sexy reject for so long love
you buddy hope you're having a great day [Music]